ça lui rendre a dit donc falloir
désormais ils ont une drôle de forme
qu'est ce que tu fais comme sport de la
polyphonie je suis humoriste amateurs
c'est bizarre on dérape ed des tranches
de coppa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous connaissez le rugby est ce que vous
aimez le rugby tout le monde aime le
rugby ses valeurs ses combats ses héros
ses chevauchées ses troisièmes mi temps
ces calendriers bon mais est-ce que vous
avez remarqué la particularité des
joueurs de rugby
je vais à part le fait qu'ils soient
tous taillés comme des persos de street
fighter qui joue avec un ballon qui
rebondit n'importe comment et qui
mangent des pistes coach le genre zoreil
enfin j'ai récemment eu la chance de
pouvoir côtoyer de très près
quelques-uns des plus beaux spécimens
orale de la planète ovale au tournoi des
six nations
[Musique]
en français comme en anglais on appelle
ça poétiquement des oreilles en
chou-fleur même si moi ça me fait plutôt
penser à des avec mac machine ça
s'explique en fait par deux autres
particularités l'une liée au rugby et
l'autre liée aux oreilles
un peu comme la lutte la boxe le judo
etc le rugby à l'espiègle habitude de
taquiner très fort ce qu'on appelle le
pavillon de l'oreille
c'est la partie qu'on voit de
l'extérieur elle est frotté plier
malaxer elle reçoit des coups se forme
alors des collections de sang
une collection de sang en fait ça veut
dire un hématome un hôte hématome même
c'est à dire un hématome de l'oreille
qui se forme entre la peau et le
cartilage et il se trouve que les
hématomes de l'oreille ne sont pas des
hématomes comme les autres d'abord parce
que contrairement à ce que vous faites
quand vous vous cogner un membre il se
résorbe très mal ensuite parce qu'ils
ont tendance à se fit bronzé voir se
qualifier c'est à dire qu'il reste en
place durcissent et ça modifie la forme
de l'oreille quand ils sont mal ou pas
du tout soigner ses hématomes peuvent
entraîner une chondrite c'est à dire une
inflammation du cartilage et une perry
chondrites c'est à dire une inflammation
des tissus qui entourent le cartilage
cdma taux longs aussi la fâcheuse
tendance d'empêcher le 110 riquet
correctement le cartilage qui finit par
mourir donc se déformer ce qui donne cet
aspect caractéristique d'une espèce de
pâtisseries dans laquelle on aurait ni
trop de levure alors la question que
vous allez poser c mais alors pourquoi
tous les joueurs de rugby n'ont pas les
oreilles en chou-fleur
non c'est trop tard d'abord parce que
tous les postes ne sont pas exposés de
la même façon
ensuite parce qu'il existe des
protections qui sont plus ou moins
efficaces comme le casque par exemple
que je portais personnellement cours de
ma carrière comme les bandes des last
hope la sq on entoure autour de la tête
et qu'on peut même parfois complétée de
deux mille balles de tennis pour bien
isoler les oreilles ensuite parce qu'il
ya des traitements immédiatement après
l'apparition d'un hématome
on peut mettre une poche de glace dessus
pour limiter le saignement un médecin
peut ensuite faire une incision au
niveau de l'oreille pour drainer le sens
où la spirée avec une grosse aiguille
après ça il faut appliquer un pansement
qui comprime bien l'oreille pour éviter
que le saignement reprennent certains
petits malins utilisent même des
sangsues pour aspirer le sens de leurs
oreilles mais les spécialistes ont
quelques doutes sur la réelle efficacité
de la méthode
la dernière solution consiste à avoir
recours à la chirurgie plastique pour
remodeler le pavillon ça reste purement
esthétique parce que les oreilles en
chou-fleur ça n'est pas dangereux
ça peut juste être un petit peu embêtant
si la déformation bouche le conduit
auditif externe ce qui diminue
l'audition bon pour la chirurgie vaut
mieux attendre la fin de carrière
histoire de pas avoir besoin de tout
recommencer au bout de six mois
mais c'est toute façon assez rare que
les joueurs aient recours un peu pour
les mêmes raisons qui font qu'ils sont
pas plus
brass protéger oui les oreilles en
chou-fleur c'est à la fois un signe
d'appartenance à la grande famille du
rugby mais aussi une sorte de trophée
mais indique qu'on a été un valeureux
combattants oui alors heureusement que
ça touche que les oreilles quand même et
heureusement que c'est des choux-fleurs
rocher voit la dtcc fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle vidéo d'ici là mollo
sur les biscottes
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]